vous le savez tout cette semaine toute
cette semaine la rédaction se mobilise
pour partager avec vous quelques bons
plans et essayer de lutter contre
l'inflation troisième volet de notre
série aujourd'hui on vous explique le
fonctionnement du Crédit Municipal un
établissement de prêt sur gage que vous
pouvez retrouver à Orléans ou tours un
moyen rapide d'obtenir de l'argent que
nous présente Aurélie Renaud
donc là c'est un diamant le Crédit
Municipal prête de l'argent suite au
dépôt de bien précieux à 90% des bijoux
mais les clients viennent aussi avec des
tableaux des bronzes des sacs à main ou
encore des grands crus à chaque dépôt
l'objet est estimé nous allons regarder
si c'est de l'or 18 carats nous allons
garder s'il y a des pierres et en
fonction de ça on va déterminer le
montant que l'on peut prêter les
personnes respropriétaires ils peuvent
récupérer leurs biens à tout moment
moyennant le remboursement du prêt les
prêts sur gage sont proposés pour une
période renouvelable de six mois et les
taux d'intérêt sont très faibles environ
70 euros pour 1000 euros empruntés
aujourd'hui Zoulikha fêter plusieurs
colliers on lui en propose 200 euros la
jeune femme s'est déjà vu prêter presque
10.000 euros par le Crédit Municipal ces
dernières années des sommes qui lui
permettent des défis financièrement son
père mais également de subvenir aux
besoins de ses enfants
avec loyer chez une femme séparée avec
trois enfants c'est ça c'est compliqué
la vie maintenant
moyenne de la somme prêtée moins de 1000
euros par client de l'argent en liquide
disponible et immédiatement finir la fin
de mois pour changer sa machine à laver
parce qu'elle est tombé en panne après
vous avez des personnes qui ont accès au
monde bancaire mais pour des raisons de
facilité ou de confidentialité préfèrent
déposer de leurs objets auxquels
municipales l'an dernier l'agence du
Crédit Municipal de Tours a prêté 3
millions et demi d'euros